lo describió como una prueba para
nuestros tiempos yo bailé dice que él
planea proteger los derechos de los
votantes y culpa a los republicanos de
un asalto a la democracia gmail es
tiempo de cesar a mí es simple
esto es una subversión electoral es la
amenaza más peligrosa de nuestra
historia del derecho al voto y para la
integridad de las elecciones libres y
justas nunca antes habían decidido quién
cuenta o qué votos cuentan web
los republicanos afirman que necesitan
reglas más duras para garantizar la
seguridad de los votantes luego de que
donald trump se quejará sin tener
pruebas de fraude durante las elecciones
presidenciales de 2020
varios estados controlados por
republicanos han introducido nuevas
restricciones este año incluyendo la
reducción de la votación por correo y
recortando los tiempos de apertura de
las urnas texas es el último lugar donde
ocurrió con los demócratas saliendo del
estado para bloquear la aprobación de
legislación impulsada por los
republicanos para reformar las leyes de
votación el martes el líder de la
minoría en el senado mitch mcconnell fue
despectivo sobre los esfuerzos
demócratas de gates a 40 es interesante
ver a la mayoría demócrata en el senado
preocupada por los derechos de la
minoría en el senado estatal de tejas
creo que si vives lo suficiente ves casi
de todo por aquí
[Música]
los demócratas afirman que esas medidas
son un intento velado para restringir
los derechos democráticos argumentando
que apuntan injustamente a los votantes
afro y a los de izquierda pero por ahora
los esfuerzos por apuntalar los derechos
de los votantes se han estancado en el
congreso ya que los republicanos están
usando las reglas del filibustero una
técnica de obstrucción para asegurarse
de que las legislaciones no se aprueben